on est en train de les ranger après les
travaux
kevin est un fidèle client deux à trois
fois par semaine il fait un tour ici à
la librairie le millefeuille de trappes
ils ont plein de livres ils sont pas
chères c'est surtout ça c'est on arrive
à avoir trouvé des idées des livres
vraiment de qualité en très bon état
pour pour un prix défiant toute
concurrence au total quelques trente
mille livres y sont stockés des livres
pas cher fournis gratuitement par des
particuliers qui voulait s'en
débarrasser
certaines médiathèque qui participe
aussi au final seulement 30% des livres
sont conservés le reste partant
recyclage car en plus d'être libraire le
millefeuille fait aussi papeterie son
atelier à redémarrer il y a tout juste
une semaine nous on va récupérer le
carton derrière en revanche pour
refabriquer toute la partie papeterie de
la librairie donc on fabrique des petits
des petits objets des petits carnets des
petites choses comme ça des répertoires
des voix la
librairie papeterie mais aussi chantier
d'insertion professionnelle grâce à un
contrat de travail en partenariat avec
le conseil général des yvelines 12
salariés sont embauchés pour une période
de six mois à un an l'équipe des douze
salariés qui travaillent ici sont des
personnes en difficulté qui avait des
difficultés de retour à l'emploi donc
qui sont embauchés à la librairie c'est
le concept en fait c'est du retour à
l'emploi par l'emploi
installé depuis sept ans sur trappe la
librairie a déménagé il y a un an avant
situé en bordure de nationale dans un
ancien appartement le magasin
fonctionnait surtout grâce au bouche à
oreille aujourd'hui avec une meilleure
visibilité beaucoup de choses ont changé
ça a été beaucoup de rencontres beaucoup
de contacts beaucoup de gens qui sont
venus beaucoup de gens qui adhèrent au
projet donc ça a été vraiment une année
très très riche et là on repart vraiment
content là ça a vraiment un très très
bon bilan des premières années installés
ici on a vu à la rentrée scolaire les
liens qui se sont créés les gens
viennent facilement nous voir pour harry
savent qu'ils peuvent avoir le livre qui
est demandée en classe pour 50 centimes
plutôt que 8 euros dans le commerce
voilà qui vit n'a trouvé son bonheur il
repart avec deux livres d'histoire il
faut 4 euros